down the skyline staircase through an
airlock steel door say Ichiro Nishimoto
welcomes us into his insurance against
Kim jong-un and Donald Trump tell me
what we're sitting in a shelter against
nuclear fallout 55 years ago when I
started selling shelters in Japan people
thought I was crazy he says who's crazy
now he asks as North Korea edges closer
to a long-range missile capable of
hitting the u.s. in America's new
president engaging in a war of words
with Kim jong-un they will be met with
fire and fury like the world has never
seen
Japan caught in the crosshairs of any
conflict in Trump's first six months as
president Mishimoto has sold more than a
dozen of his tropical-themed concrete
fortified shelters well that's not a lot
that's more than he sold in 55 years
housing developer Kazuma yoshiyama wants
in our customers asking for this yeah
how many of these are you thinking of
building yeah maybe it may not seem as
ridiculous as it sounds in a suburban
neighborhood in Wakayama Japan nestled
behind this traditional Japanese home
what is this made out of
Cory wanted this guy concrete concrete
so three layers of reinforced concrete
right here Yoshihiko kounotori bought
this small shelter fearing earthquakes
tsunami and the neighbor to his north I
always worry about the nuclear by North
Korea having the shelter does it give
you peace of mind that's right I feel
very peaceful selling that personal
peace in these shelters that range from
tens to hundreds of thousands of dollars
but you won't hear Nishimoto celebrate
the windfall Trump's extreme rhetoric
has heightened tensions with North Korea
he says you
don't know what he's going to do next
it's good if it goes well but if it
doesn't it could lead to a national
disaster night go ahead and say they're
prepping for the impossible but for a
region watching to unpredictable leaders
they call it just being realistic
jung-hwa CNN Osaka Japan